ce matin le chef de l'état est encore
rattrapé par son duel avec jean luc
mélenchon qui l'accusent 30 et est
spécialiste de ça avant de monter dans
l'avion l'insulté tout le monde et puis
monter dans l'avion je veux juste
espérer que le président français n'at
il pas prendre toutes les mauvaises
habitudes de monsieur tron
notamment face à un mauvais résultat
électoral le air sarko one au passage
recyclés en air mac ont tous un c'est
qu'on veut signifier la république et
que finalement si on a besoin de gros
jouer comme ça pour singer l'autorité
c'est que on en a pas beaucoup de
charisme naturel faudra m'expliquer en
quoi venir prennent nos soldats est une
forme de mépris
c'est un respect affiché se sont pas
bien il se sent pas bien pourquoi la
réalité même plus profonde que ce qui se
passe sur législatives la réalité que
c'est que le projet que porte emmanuel
macron est aujourd'hui minoritaire dans
le pays donc j'assume comme d'habitude
tout avec clarté et sérénité ça ne
trompe plus personne ce exact permanence
ce en même temps neutrons barre à gauche
puis cette mise en scène là au pied de
l'avion ça ressemble à rien c'est une
forme de sauve-qui-peut sent quand même
un sauve qui peut
cette déclaration c'est jugeant vite au
pied de mon avion ça ressemble à un
sauve qui peut mais aujourd'hui
il en est responsable je suis pas
mélenchonistes ça vous a pas échappé moi
je suis écologiste donc nous avons des
différences mais dans cette dans cette
campagne législative quand on voit les
urgences à tous points de vue qui
veulent pas avoir une opposition le
couteau entre les dents à la mélenchon a
vociféré à être dans l'extrémisme à être
aussi dans des positions sont anti
républicaine sans la police scandale
cette coalition elle offre un avenir à
ce pays qui est bien plus sympathique
bienveillant solidaire que
l'avenir que nous que nous promet
monsieur macron à la fête chez moi et
moi existant sur nos plateaux oui mais
bien vite vous faites moins qu'en 2006
philippe arnould canonisé on investira
ce matin c'était l'épreuve de philo pour
en demi million de candidats sur ces
images de xavier bommel un lycée à
nantes parmi les sujets de cette année
les pratiques artistiques
transforme-t-elle le monde et revient-il
à l'état de décider de ce qui est juste
les commentateurs avaient dit on va se
retrouver à dix mais vous êtes al kass
vous êtes à 11 m'a dit pas non mais
ça nous arrangerait non pas du tout y
arriver à marange dommage mais non
madame dati je vous assure technologies
qu'ils avaient le choix entre la liberté
consiste t la n'obéira personnes est-il
juste de défendre ses droits par tous
les moyens ces jeunes de banlieues
françaises au coeur d'une controverse
aux pays bas le ministre des affaires
sociales néerlandais a proposé aux
entreprises du pays de les recruter au
pallier la pénurie de main d'oeuvre et
de les remettre je cite dans le droit
chemin dans le calvados la première
ministre interpellé après un nouveau
témoignage de femmes qui dit avoir subi
une tentative de viol en 2010 ce site
mediapart a révélé qu'une élue centriste
accuse damien abad d'avoir tenté de la
violer lors d'une fête parisienne en
2010 un témoignage qui pour l'instant
n'est pas assortie d'une plainte qu'un
homme utilise sont sa stature d'homme de
pouvoir pour avoir des faveurs ça vous
dérange pas bien sûr qu'il me dérange
mais je suis d'accord l'attendait mais
bien a dit attendez madame je peux c'est
pas moi qui ai moi je suis pas juge vous
savez je suis pas juge l'a pour
l'instant on a des témoignages anonymes
dans un journal campagnes de la croix
rouge contre la canicule et bien figurez
vous que cette campagne fait polémique
parce qu'on y voit dessus et vous le
voyez on y voit une femme voilée max et
emme et en haut notre pays je suis
désolé en tant que femme je ne me sens
pas en sécurité
il ya des lois qui font qu'on peut pas
effectivement abusé de sa position pour
obtenir des faveurs comme vous dites en
effet vous ne mettez pas de côté les
personnes qui posent problème et ça les
femmes on peut pas vous faire confiance
je suis désolé